Evon pi is writing out the storm in Kure
Beach North Carolina it's one of the
barrier island towns that has the
Atlantic Ocean on the one side and the
Cape Fear River on the other just south
of Wilmington he joins us by phone evan
good morning hey how are you guys doing
today we're doing ok we are worried
about how you're doing are you in the
middle of the eye of the storm right now
and what's it like there yes actually
I'm standing outside right now in the
eye just kind of assessing the situation
around me in the neighborhood a bunch of
trees down breath lots of stuff in the
in the streets some windows broken
oceanfront houses sinking trash cans in
the ocean mostly everything is okay
vitally but there are some damages out
here I don't see any roads really shut
down from trees being crossed completely
over but there is a bunch of shrubbery
and stuff like that strong everywhere
but it's uh that's part doing pretty
good well Evan we talked to your
governor earlier this morning he said
most people heeded orders and decided to
leave the area why did you decide to
stay and how are you staying safe well I
stayed because this is my hometown and I
had a really weird feeling in my chest
that I needed to stay home and make sure
that everybody around me is okay because
I do give me really I'd really care
about them a lot so I stayed here just
out of my own appeal so I just stayed
here making sure my uncle's okay there
he's one of my next-door neighbors make
sure my neighbor's houses are okay
there's a couple cats that I'm watching
for our neighbors and stuff like that
and that's just I don't know I just
needed to stay with my home so how did
you prepare Avenue to take care of all
those people while while this is
happening I got a bunch of gear a bunch
of stuff that Kay BPD's actually
supplied me with to make sure that the
neighborhood's going to be okay of
course stocked up on water boarded up my
own house help the neighbors board up
everything but every you know other than
that everything seems to be okay I know
we're about to get hit with the back
wall we're in the eye right now
so I'm observing very slowly so we'll
probably be in a storm for the rest of
the day until nightfall well we all wish
we could have neighbors like you haven't
your uncle doing did he end up staying
yeah he's saying he's actually right
here with me everything's good we've got
the generators running and we're kind of
walking around the neighborhood making
sure everybody else is ok and assessing
the situation of our neighbors houses
found some broken windows on one of my
across the street neighbor's house and
it's oceanfront I'm like two streets
away from the ocean so I walk down there
and so I called him and texted him and
let him know as his windows busted and
we're actually in the process of trying
to avoid that up needless to say they
owe you a few souvenirs from wherever
they ended up going 'event evan evan pi
let me just say this about you you sound
so calm insane under what are very
dangerous conditions
yes ma'am I've been prepared for a day
like this for a while my dad he's he's
wrote out every storm and I've wrote out
a couple throughout the years probably
about four or five years ago I snuck
through I can't remember the name of it
but I think it was a cat 3 and I was
oceanfront within was waves that were
18-foot touching my back porch and still
remained pretty calm I don't know
something about this just you know makes
me want to stay home all right take care
of your uncle on that cat and the
neighbors homes and take care of
yourself
of course y'all stay thank you keep us
posted Thank You Evan I will